[Musique]
1er novembre 2001 couple dans la
cinquantaine de ces jean sur richelieu
en montérégie ont rendez vous en suisse
plus précisément à zurich
le couple est là pour ouvrir un compte
il rencontre banquiers d'une société
assez particulière la banque privée
tempus réservé aux plus fortunés du
monde
je pense tellement privé qu'elle ne
s'affiche pas de la rue clients et
banquiers se rencontrent souvent dans
des hôtels plutôt qu'à la banque
premier geste remplir le formulaire à le
seul document qui permet d'identifier
les véritables détenteurs des comptes en
suisse et cette journée là le couple
prend plusieurs décisions
[Musique]
le compte sera conjoint ce sera un
contest numéro et aucune trace de leur
identité ne devra apparaître sur les
relevés
il donnera dresse sur la rue coulon à
saint jean sur richelieu le comblement
de ces passeports canadiens comme preuve
d'identité sur un autre formulaire que
nous avons vu l'homme indique qu'il est
consultant le couple décide que les
fonds déposés seront investis de façon
conservatrice nos emerging markets group
autrement dit pas de risque les deux
signes et il faut un autre choix celui
du nom de code pour leur compte ils
choisissent zorro
[Musique]
le conte euro va tous vous intéresser il
montre que le fédéral n'est pas à l'abri
de la corruption
contes oraux appartient à l'ancien pdg
de la société des ponts fédéraux
michel fournier et à sa femme à cette
société michel fournier cumule les
postes président des ponts jacques
cartier et champlain incorporée en plus
de la direction de la société qui
chapeaute ce sont des sociétés d'état
responsable de la gestion et de
l'entretien des bons internationaux et
fédéraux les sociétés qui dépensent près
de 100 millions par année
michel fournier et au libéral notoire
chef de cabinet de jean chrétien
lorsqu'elle est dans l'opposition
directeur général de l'ailé québécoise
du parti libéral
jusqu'à sa nomination à la société des
ponts lorsque les conservateurs prennent
le pouvoir à ottawa puis celle fournie
le libéral perd son poste en 2007 et la
55 ans il quitte la société des ponts la
politique vend sa maison de saint jean
sur richelieu et semblent disparaître
nous l'avons retrouvé ici loin des ponts
et d'effroi montréalais au bout de la
route
sur cette colline en banlieue de
victoria en colombie britannique
je suis tombé sur les informations assez
importante que vous nous expliquer ce
qui s'est passé pour sauver votre
gestion de la société d'état concernant
un compte vous aviez ouvert en suisse et
allemand qui ont été faites dans votre
compte
donc oui vous aviez un coup vers un
compte en banque tempus 15 euros oui
vous avez reçu plusieurs paiements de la
société snc lavalin dans ce qu'on classe
g cham berges propres en aucune façon
banale
ces informations proviennent de l'
enquête sur iad benaïssa vous vous
souvenez cet ex vice président de snc
lavalin qui est emprisonné en suisse
depuis près de deux ans pour avoir versé
d'importants pots-de-vin à des ex
dictateur comme kadhafi en libye
surprenant alors de voir le nom de
michel fournier apparaître dans ce
dossier et recevoir des millions de
dollars en versements suspects n'ont
jamais ouvert de compte entre votre
votre passeport était de leur garantie
on joue des photos fournies j'ai vu les
photos de votre passeport attaché à ce
compte là qui s'appelle zorro que vous
avez appelé euros à la banque pincus
écoutez madame je sais pas j'ai pas eu
de compte que j'ai ouvert des portes
pourtant les documents bancaires et
juridiques donne des détails troublants
de janvier à octobre 2002 promo tag une
agence régulièrement engagé par snc
lavalin dépose des sommes importantes
dans le conte zorro
deux cent trente mille dollars 228 1114
mais cette fois pour un total de plus de
2 millions de dollars
j'aimerais monsieur hire vous montrez ce
formulaire qui le formulaire à pour
ouvrir un compte en suisse
messaoud abda est un expert en
criminalité financière
écoutez d'après ce que je vois ici lui
il n'y a pas de doute là de la personne
a été identifiée physiquement dans les
lois suisses donc on peut pas juste par
procuration ouvrir un compte à quelqu'un
qui est ailleurs il faut absolument
qu'ils soient présents qu'on constate
son identité jeu qu'on le fasse signer
clément côté a été son compagnon de
route à la société pendant des années sa
signature et devient un crime ce jeu là
reconnaît sa signature vicieusement
maintenant que gilles documents sur les
lieux l'eau ça me surprend pas où
j'étais j'ai tombé brocante mode solo
mais ça me surprend pas
que se passe-t-il à ce moment là qui
pourrait justifier ces paiements de 2000
à 2002 la société des ponts a entrepris
un grand chantier au bon jacques cartier
rappelez vous il s'agissait de refaire
tout le tablier du pont de nuit pour ne
pas perturber le trafic
un contrat de 127 millions de dollars
effectué par un consortium dirigé par
snc lavalin selon michel fournier
l'appel d'offres a été fait dans les
règles de l'art je pense que c'est parce
ailleurs mais je peux vous dire que chez
nous tout aussi été fait de façon très
très très très propre ils étaient les
plus bas soumissionnaire visa de la
meilleure note technique explique moi
pourquoi ces gens nord était stupide
à un tel point de dire est prêt à
l'automne et à sang et ça c'est sûr que
ça a l'air est relié avec les ponts mais
ce qu'on lui l'eau c'était le meilleur
tout grands tubes en voici fait la
magouille comment s'est faite la
magouille là où je les sculpter chez csc
chez les extras qu'est-ce qu'elle a eu
dans ce dossier notre bien hâte à
trouveront des extras on peut structurer
des transactions pour que la société ou
le leu leu leu le soumissionnaire voulu
soit le dernier le plus bas
soumissionnaire donc les différentes
façons soit ne donne de l'information
sur la soumission en lui donne des fois
on lui dit carrément comme soumissionner
dit dans ce cas ci malheureusement la
société d'ingénierie impliqué c'est un
expert dans les appels d'offres
le 12 octobre 2000 le contrat est donnée
snc lavalin deux semaines plus tard le
1er novembre
le couple fourni ouvre son compte en
suisse fin 2002 les travaux au pont
jacques cartier se termine
le couple ferme ce compte et transfère 2
millions de dollars dans une autre
banque pasche leurs comptes s'appelle
alors saint jean laville qui l'habite
alors promoteurs continuent de leur
verser des sommes jusqu'en 2004 deux
déversements serait liée à des contrats
en libye
s'étonne les enquêteurs suisses car
michel fournier est encore à l'emploi de
la société des ponts au canada j'ai
jamais reçu painchaud de l'apport de la
snc lavalin de promo tag s'émousse
quelque chose lagence commerciales
utilisées par snc lavalin pour tout sur
le dos il s'appelle promoteurs n'ont
jamais reçu le projet la justice suisse
profonde pour poser des questions aux
gens des saints et revenait sur 1 4
million $ qui a été versée à votre
compte
écoutez j'ai jamais reçu de son août
snc lavalin si quelqu'un polaire les
paiements sur son compte la part d'une
partie de chasse qu'il ne connaît pas
c'est à dire que ce qui lui qui de facto
il
il confie où il admet que finalement il
se connaît
ce n'est pas tout en 2009 le couple
fournier ferme son compte mais on ouvre
notre toujours à la même banque
il transfère ensuite une partie de sa
fortune dans le compte suisse de flou
nast une société incorporée aux îles
vierges britanniques qui leur appartient
aux cinq questions que nous avons posées
à snc-lavalin nous n'avons reçu qu'une
phrase en réponse nous n'avons pas
d'informations à partager relativement
vos questions quant à glencore lune
l'actuel directeur de la société des
ponts jacques cartier et champlain
il a refusé notre offre de le rencontrer
qu'est-ce que pu dérailler qu'est ce qui
fait que non ça pas de rayer noxa pareil
c'est pas leur est fournie saint-brieuc
- love malheureux pas solo puis là je
m'aperçois alors que c'est nous on était
peut-être les couvertures la course tout
seul ce ces choses une semaine plus tard
michel fournier a rappelé au téléphone
il admet avoir bel et bien ouvert le
fameux conte euros mais dit-il comme
prête nom pour sa belle soeur
aujourd'hui décédé qui voulait toucher
de l'argent son conjoint émis vous avez
aucune explication je consommais
paiement promoting comment éludé des
paiements de promoteurs ont que vous
tire sur votre compte même si vous dites
qu'il a été ouvert comme prénom non pas
vous mais pour vos soeurs pourquoi ta
soeur recevrait des paiements de
promoteur et c'est ainsi que promo tag
aurait pu lui verser des sommes
importantes pendant des années et tout
cela selon lui
à son issue